in a recent study it was found that
balloons
what's wrong tarik
oh um nothing
[Music]
terrig
i know i should be excited that this is
our first episode of season two but
there's so much bad stuff happening in
the world right now it makes me mad
you seem fine how do you deal with it oh
it's easy i focus all my anger on one
small trivial thing from the past
how
i'll show you in a segment called being
mad like it's 1995.
[Music]
this is legendary group tlc i think
about them a lot they didn't deserve
what happened to them and i'm still mad
about it in 1995 they released the song
waterfalls from their smash hit album
crazy sexy cool in addition to the
amazing vocals and catchy hook the song
is deep touching on topics like hiv and
drug dealing it's just a perfectly put
together song so many nice things were
said about it like this song is great yo
this is the best song ever everyone else
stop making music this song wins wait
wait wait wait
who said that me all of those quotes are
from me
this song was a hit all around the world
at its peak you couldn't turn on mtv
without seeing that music video
mtv is a channel that before its current
program schedule of teen pregnancy
reality shows used to actually show
music videos
music videos are a thing that we will
watch if we really like the song it's
like those tic tac tick tock dance
videos but not at all and way longer i
love that video it is so awesome it is
then why are you mad
because the song waterfalls had a
fantastic ramp in it but the radio edit
version of the song has no rap a perfect
song was ruined they took the rap from
lisa left eye lopez out of the song and
it was a crime and it is my personal
belief that the removal of left eyes rap
from the radio edit is what stopped the
song from becoming the national anthem
amber
we are all in agreement
please continue and left eye wasn't some
random guest rapper she's the l in tlc
she starts reverse with i seen a rainbow
yesterday and as soon as i heard that i
was like you did left eye you had better
speak on it and she did it is such a
great verse it is one of the best parts
of music in the 90s and does not get
enough praise the radio edits removal of
left eyes verse hurt the song's
popularity i believe that is the reason
why it lost both its grammy nominations
including the grammy for best duo or
group which went to let her cry by hooty
and the blue fish
that group only had one song and that
wasn't it
i would like to speak to the person who
started taking the rap part out of songs
on pop radio and ask
what was the reason is a 45 second rap
too aggressive for y'all are you scared
your kids are going to enjoy black art
and start imitating it what's the worst
that could happen
[Music]
okay well
we are both making points you have a
point you do have a point i hated to
hear it but
it's not like listening to rap will make
drake magically appear and give you a
grilled gang membership and a fubu
jacket
bobo is a clothing company
the corporate excuse for the radio edit
is that it allows them to play a shorter
version of the song but the radio edit
always takes out the rap verse why in
many cases it is the best part case in
point no diggity
we're the party at black jagged edge
featuring nelly stutter by joe featuring
mystical look you guys are so young
[Applause]
mother have not heard of one of them
no
mommy turned down your music in the car
give us what the artists intend
is there is rap music still around i
don't even know anymore i feel okay
baby shark
is that a wrap
that's the that's the latest song reach
me that is it
so
out of touch look
go on twitter and tag amber and tarek
with your songs that you think we should
know
look give us what the artists intended
we still see companies cutting the red
side of songs and calling it a radio
edit y'all ain't slick it's subtle
racism disguised as saving time if
you're scared you're gonna like it
that's for you to deal with the rest of
us just wanna dance
[Music]
it makes me want to get out of my body
and run away it's the kid
i'm sure he is an adorable sweet child
it is the blonde kid and the i want to
hug him and say never do that again
don't you ever do that again it is the
same feeling as if like if a dog came in
here and attacked one of us yeah that's
the feeling it feels like
there's nothing you can do you know what
it feels like remember in the matrix
when they were getting the plugs pulled
out of their heads yes girl was like not
like this
not like this it feels like that yes
that's it
we may have gotten off track bottom line
is that left eyes rap versus waterfalls
is iconic if you haven't listened to the
song in a while which you have not i
highly recommend that you do it will
make you so happy and then angry that
the people in charge try to give us a
watered-down version in order to stifle
black excellence which will distract you
from all the crappy things happening
today so why get mad at things that are
happening in 2021 when you can be mad
like it's 1995.
[Music]
you